welcome back to 8701
uh with this lecture i'd like to
introduce the major players of this
class the particles
fundamental fundamental particles
but also some of the compound particles
which play a role in the discussions
we'll have over the next weeks
for centuries people believed
that atoms are
the most fundamental constitutions of
matter
the name atom comes from the greek
atomic which means
not divisible but as you know today
electrons and nuclei build an atom
but even those nuclei are not
fundamental particles
as you see nicely here in this picture
the nuclei is built off
and can be built out of many neutrons
and protons
and even those protons and neutrons are
not fundamental particles
a proton for example is depicted here um
has three components or three
constituents um
two up to up quarks and one down quark a
neutron then
is built out of one down quark and two
up quarks
um it is kind of important to understand
and appreciate
the size of those particles
um specifically the difference in size
comparing here an
atom a typical atom of the size of 10 to
the minus 10 meters
and that compares to a nucleon which can
be a few
10 10 to the minus 15 meters
when we talk about a proton typically
like to use
um units of femtometers which is 10
minus 10 to the minus 15 meters
um the tremendous size different
also explains the finding of the famous
gold foil experiment
which found that an atom basically is
made out of
nothingness empty space and a very dense
charged core the nucleus so you see this
very much in this picture and by
comparing those order of magnitudes
not shown in this picture here is a
particle
which doesn't really like to interact
with anybody else
or which the forces it's interacting
with are so weak that it cannot be
bound and that is certain neutrino a
neutrino is not that different from an
electron
or from a quark it's just that the
interactions
it participates in um
are only the weak force as we understand
today
um just to be clear when i talk about a
fundamental particle i talk about a
particle
um which has no size it's
infinitely infinitely small
um it has no substructure meaning it
cannot be broken up in constituents
um and can also not be excited
having said that this is our current
understanding of nature
and of those particles experimentally we
can only probe
those particles to a certain scale or
size
and we'll talk later about how precisely
we actually do know that a quark is
fundamental
or an electron is fundamental
in this discussion here in most of the
lecture i'll talk about a standard model
in particle physics
it is a fact that our measurements
and our experimental of findings are in
uh fantastic agreement with this very
predictive predictive
theory um the only
uh experimental deviation from this is
the fact that we measure the mass of
neutrinos to be non-zero
um as a consequence you know you could
say the standard model is broken or we
found physics beyond the standard model
but it is actually rather
straightforward to extend the standard
model to accommodate neutrino masses so
we can
you know just forget about this small
fact and assume that the standard model
described nature as we know it
in the last week of this class we'll
talk about
motivation why you think that the
standard model in fact is not complete
and one of the big drivers here is the
fact that we cannot
observe describe all of the observations
in nature
specifically the observation of dark
matter
with the standard model in multiple
physics but that's for later day
looking into some more detail the
standard model has
sets of particles some are particles
which carry forces
and some are metaparticles the ones who
carry forces are all spin-one vertical
particles and their bosons with that
we have in the standard model describe
three interactions the electromagnetic
interactions which you all know from
light electromagnetic phenomena
chemistry you know the atoms behavior
molecule
is determined by electromagnetic
interactions
and then there's a strong interaction
the name already tells you that it's
strong it's very strong
um the fourth carrier here is the gluon
each clue
the plunge there's eight and that
differentiated
differentiate by the so-called color
which is an interesting effect
and then there is the weak interaction
um carried by the w boson and the z
boson they are different they're on
right because they carry a mass they are
massive particles and they're actually
quite heavy
about 80 to 100 times as heavy
as a proton
um the weak interaction is responsible
for neutron decays
also responsible for the burning of the
sun and in our nuclear physics part
we'll talk
in detail about what that all means the
gravitational effects are not considered
in the standard model they're very very
weak
compared to the strength of the other
forces we'll discuss here
but it's technically very difficult to
actually accommodate
gravity as part of a quantum field
theory
and therefore we can we will simply
ignore this fact
and that's yet another reason why you
can consider the standard model to be
incomplete as a
model or theory describing nature
the metaparticles themselves are all
fermions they have spin half
and they come in three different
generations the only difference between
one generation to the next is the fact
that
those particles have different mass
in other words their coupling to the
higgs field is different
and that's the only difference between
those particles there's consequences
out of this for example heavier
particles
can decay into lighter particles
we differentiate between the quarks and
leptons quarks
partake in the strong interactions where
leptons are neutral
in the strong interaction and then we
have seen neutrinos already and
electron type particles electron type
particles
the charged leptons they have electric
charge so they
coupled to photons by neutrinos don't
i show you here again one of those
striking differences
an electron is 9 times 10 to the minus
31 kilogram heavy
we like to talk about units in a
different class
but that's 511 kev
why the muon is about 200 times heavier
and even heavier as a tower lepton
as i said before that allows the tau
lepton and also the muons to decay into
lighter particles
i will talk about this this and how how
we can use those decays in order to
learn about the standard modulator
and then there is a higgs boson and
again the higgs boson discovered in 2012
space plays a very special role in the
in the standard mode
we talked about the lagrange and the
theory
um which describes the standard model or
which is you know the basic there's a
theory itself
later on in this theory we introduce a
potential which is shown here this
mexican head if you want potential and
what you see here is that in this
picture that the lowest energy state of
this potential
breaks a symmetry so it's away from the
zero point
and that symmetry breaking then gives
mass to the w and the z boson which i
was describing before
and the coupling of metaparticles to the
higgs field gives masses as particles
all this on a later date i thought here
i also give you how cern actually
depicts
um the higgs boson july 4th is a special
day in the us but it's also a special
day
at cern because the higgs discovery has
been announced on this day
and at cern typically the menu is
enriched on that day
by the higgs borden itself in form of
pizza
which takes the shape of event displays
displays of protein potent collisions
into the higgs boson and then
further decays we look at some of those
event displays also later
so that completes the elementary the
fundamental particles of the standard
model
are particles which describe almost
everything around us
so we have seen the charge in neutral
leptons we have seen the quarks
we have seen the force carriers is a wz
boson the proton and the blue one
and the higgs boson which you know is
kind of the
very special particle holding this all
together
um an interesting point here is again
looking a little bit at history
and when those particles have been
discovered
and also when those particles have been
explained um and i don't want to read
this all to you um you'd see that you
know the earliest discovery was the
discovery by
jj thompson of the electron and the
latest
the completion of the particles in the
standard model
the higgs boson in 2012. interesting for
the higgs boson
the time between the theoretical
discovery by peter hicks
in france was about 50 years before the
experimental discovery
but then there is also composite
particles the things around you are all
composite particles
um here we can differentiate between
mesons and baryons
mesons are particles which are made out
of quarks and anti-core pairs
of the bound states and they are botonic
because you add
in half part two spin half particles
together
one example is a pion which is made out
of up quarks and down quarks
that can be charged in neutral ions
and the the zoo of particle increases
quite
quickly uh if you then consider that
it's not just up and down clocks making
those particles but you could add
strangeness to that meaning a strange
quark and so you see here in this
in this picture um
the mesons the pions attas but also then
neutrals and charged particles with
different charges and then chaons which
are particles which have
one s-clock in addition to an up
and then there's barions they're made
out of three quarks we have already seen
the proton and the neutron
but also here you can see a different
configuration
we'll introduce a concept of isospin
you can see here the proton and the
neutron and then strangeness being added
with one
or two components of strategies and then
there's this isospin component as well
this situation becomes complex very very
quickly but we'll look at this
in more detail and then again
putting those bound state together bound
states of our protons and neutrons so
the strong force
gives us a rich table of nuclei or an
isotope tape
um here you can describe nuclei by the
number of protons which is typically
called z
and the number of neutrons which is
typically called n
um the sum n plus z is the atomic mass
now each proton and the neutron are
about one gev heavy
and then the atomic mass is simply the
sum of them so you already know
explicitly
how heavy your isotope might be
we'll talk about the fact that those
masses are not quite
the sum of the masses later because
there's some binding energy involved
and then isotopes can be stable or
unstable they can decay in various
processes
you can combine them it's very
interesting to understand and how
they're actually being created
in our solar system or the universe in
general
so with this i'd like to conclude this
this part of the introduction so we have
seen
the major players of of this course with
the fundamental particles but also the
compound particles
meson variants and nuclei
and there's a few more points in the
introduction before we then dive into
a little bit more of this theoretical
discussion